Salut,
c’est Romain,
de 1000 idées de culture générale.
J’ai deux petites choses importantes
à vous dire
avant que la vidéo ne commence.
PREMIÈRE CHOSE :
ne regardez PAS
la vidéo
comme ça,
avec du pop-corn.
Si vous voulez RETENIR
ce que vous allez apprendre
dans cette vidéo,
vous DEVEZ
prendre des notes.
Les études sur la mémorisation
ne laissent AUCUNE PLACE
au doute :
NE PAS PRENDRE
DE NOTES
ÉGALE
OUBLIER.
Donc faites-moi plaisir :
ouvrez une application
comme Google Docs
ou Evernote,
et NOTEZ
ce qui est essentiel pour vous
au fur et à mesure.
SECONDE CHOSE
que je dois vous dire :
la vidéo que vous allez regarder
est extraite de ma formation
de culture générale
qui s’appelle
« Culture Express ».
C’est une formation qui permet
d’acquérir RAPIDEMENT
une bonne culture générale,
SANS
se prendre la tête,
sans avoir à lire
ni à réfléchir.
Elle couvre tous les domaines
de la culture générale :
elle permet de maîtriser
les connaissances essentielles
sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France,
en économie,
en science politique,
en psychologie,
en science,
en littérature,
en art,
en religion,
ET ENFIN...
...en philosophie
— eh oui,
c’est important
la philo.
Si ça vous intéresse,
jetez-y un coup d’œil,
soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Maintenant
je vous laisse regarder la vidéo.
Concentrez-vous,
préparez-vous
à prendre des notes,
et puis n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires.
Et moi je vous dis :
à la prochaine !
________________
Qu’est-ce que l’art ?
« L’art sauvera le monde. »
— Dostoïevski, L’Idiot
Je me souviens d’une anecdote que m’avait
racontée un ami quand j’étais adolescent
: sa mère avait trouvé des magazines pornographiques
cachés dans les affaires de son père, et
celui-ci s’était justifié en disant que
c’était de l’art. L’idée sous-jacente
à son argument, c’est que l’art est une
activité dont la noblesse intrinsèque a
le pouvoir de revaloriser des choses vulgaires
ou immorales. Les scandales de l’art contemporain
en apportent la preuve : des créations qui
frappent l’homme ordinaire par leur simplicité
(pour ne pas dire leur absence de sens) ou
par leur obscénité accèdent au statut d’«
œuvre » et entrent dans les musées.
L’argument du père de mon ami révèle
également l’ambiguïté de la définition
de l’art. Si les frontières de l’art
étaient bien établies, si nous savions dire
ce qui relève de son domaine et ce qui n’en
relève pas, alors l’art ne serait pas un
prétexte facile.
Dans cette leçon, je vais répondre aux questions
suivantes :
* Comment définir l’art ?
* Comment classifier les différents arts
?
* Quel est le sens de l’art ?
* Y a-t-il un progrès en art ?
* Qui sont les artistes ?
Comment définir l’art ?
Pour moi qui suis un amoureux de la clarté,
l’ambiguité du mot « art » est un vrai
problème. Non seulement sa définition fait
débat, mais les acteurs du monde de l’art
eux-mêmes entretiennent le flou sur les réponses
possibles (probablement pour tenir les profanes
à distance, et parce que la clarté menace
le prestige de leur profession).
Que signifie le mot « art » ?
Le nom commun « art » vient du latin ars,
qui signifie « habileté, savoir-faire ».
En adoptant la perspective de l’étymologie,
l’art est donc, dans l’absolu, une capacité
à produire un certain résultat. Il s’oppose
traditionnellement à la science, conçue
comme une connaissance indépendante des applications.
L’art d’écrire dont je me sers en ce
moment même en rédigeant le script de cette
vidéo — cet art peut par exemple être
défini comme l’ensemble des procédés
qui servent à produire le résultat que je
désire, à savoir un texte qui communique
efficacement mes idées. C’est également
dans ce sens que l’on parle des « arts
martiaux », c’est-à-dire l’ensemble
des procédés qui permettent de gagner un
combat. C’est encore dans ce sens général
que l’on parle d’un « homme de l’art
» pour désigner un spécialiste particulièrement
compétent dans sa spécialité (par exemple,
un chirurgien très habile).
« L’art de plaire est l’art de tromper.
»
— Vauvenargues (moraliste du XVIIIe siècle),
Réflexions et maximes
Le sens général du mot « art » a donné
les expressions suivantes :
* les arts dits « mécaniques », comme la
menuiserie, ou « l’art » de l’ingénieur
(même si de nos jours nous considérons l’ingénieur
comme un scientifique) ;
* les « beaux-arts », qui ont pour but,
comme leur nom l’indique, de produire le
beau (vous avez certainement entendu parler
des écoles des beaux-arts en France, qui
ont donné l’expression « faire les Beaux-arts
») : les principaux beaux-arts sont la peinture,
la sculpture, la gravure, l’architecture
et l’art décoratif ;
* les « arts libéraux », les 7 disciplines
étudiées dans les facultés de philosophie
au Moyen Âge (c’étaient, dans le détail,
la grammaire, la rhétorique, et la logique
d’une part — les trois matières qui étaient
appelées le trivium — et l’arithmétique,
la géométrie, l’astronomie, et la musique
d’autre part — les quatre matières appelées
le quadrivium).
Mais la plupart du temps, nous n’employons
plus le nom commun « art » dans le sens
très général d’une capacité à produire
un certain résultat.
Lorsque nous parlons de l’Art avec un grand
A — lorsque, par exemple, nous disons « c’est
de l’art » — dans de tels cas, l’art
désigne la production de la beauté par l’homme,
tout particulièrement la beauté visuelle
(ce qui réduit l’art aux « beaux-arts
»). L’Art avec un grand A relève de ce
que l’on appelle l’« esthétique » (je
vais revenir sur ce terme). C’est dans ce
sens que l’on parle par exemple de l’«
art classique » ou de l’« art baroque
».
« J'appelle artiste celui qui crée des formes.
»
— André Malraux, Les Voix du silence (essai
de psychologie de l’art)
Bien sûr, cette définition simple est sujette
à interprétations ; elle a évolué et elle
a été remise en cause au cours de l’histoire
de l’art.
Qu’est-ce que la beauté ?
Le nom commun « beauté » vient du latin
bellus, qui signifie « joli, gracieux, élégant
» — l’étymologie ne nous est donc d’aucune
aide pour définir la beauté.
Je vais donc plutôt partir d’exemples.
La beauté est la qualité de ce qui est « beau
» (les philosophes disent d’ailleurs « LE
beau »). Mais comment savoir si une chose
est belle ? Un paysage, par exemple, est beau
s’il déclenche en moi la sensation qu’on
qualifie d’« esthétique », c’est-à-dire
s’il produit sur mes sens une impression
comparable à celle que produisent toutes
les choses belles. Plus précisément, un
paysage est beau s’il produit sur mon sens
de la vue — qui est le sens le plus utilisé
par l’être humain — une impression agréable
(Socrate avait déjà remarqué que la beauté
n’a de sens qu’à l’égard de la vue
et de l’ouïe, mais c’est le sens de la
vue qui est l’élément crucial pour définir
la beauté au sens strict). En clair, une
chose est belle si la voir me procure une
impression agréable.
La beauté se définit donc, au sens strict,
comme la qualité qui provoque l’émotion
esthétique chez l’homme.
C’est par extension que l’on parle de
la beauté de choses qui ne sont pas perçues
par la vue, comme une chanson (principalement
perceptible par le sens de l’ouïe), ou
un poème (perceptible par une combinaison
complexe de l’ouïe [dans la mesure où
le poème doit être lu] et de la vue [dans
la mesure où le poème évoque des images]).
Mais à quoi la beauté tient-elle plus fondamentalement
?
À ma connaissance, les hommes n’ont pas
donné de réponse simple et claire à cette
question, mais deux pistes me paraissent intéressantes
:
1. sous le prisme de l’histoire de l’humanité,
la beauté serait la propriété visuelle
des choses qui sont favorables à la survie
de l’individu et de l’espèce (par exemple,
un beau paysage naturel est un milieu dans
lequel l’espèce a pu prospérer, ou encore
une belle femme est, pour un homme, une femme
fertile) ;
« La beauté réside dans les adaptations
de l’observateur. »
— Donald Symons, What Do Men Want?
2. du point de vue technique, la beauté semble
surtout tenir à l’harmonie, c’est-à-dire
au fait qu’une multiplicité d’éléments
divers forment une unité en concourant à
une même fin (l’harmonie du corps humain,
par exemple).
Comment la définition de l’art a-t-elle
évolué ?
L’évolution de la définition s’explique
par le rapport de l’art à l’artisanat.
Dans le 1er cas de figure, ils sont confondus.
« Artisan d’abord. »
— Alain, Les Arts et les Dieux
Dans les communautés où l’art est peu
développé (au sens où les œuvres d’art
produisent une émotion esthétique limitée)
— dans ces communautés, l’artiste est
un artisan, un homme habile dans un art mécanique
difficile (un horloger, par exemple) qui gagne
sa vie en produisant de beaux objets pour
des clients. Ainsi, l​​es Grecs employaient
un seul mot (technê) pour désigner l'habileté
manuelle et l'art. L’habileté de l’artisan
le distingue certes de l’ouvrier, mais son
statut social n’est guère plus enviable
: il est, comme lui, un travailleur manuel
sans noblesse. Dans l’histoire occidentale,
la confusion de l’artiste et de l’artisan
a eu cours grosso modo jusqu’à la Renaissance,
même si certains créateurs de génie ont
pu s’en émanciper lors des périodes d’épanouissement
artistique (et cela dès l’Antiquité).
Dans le 2ème cas de figure, l’art dépasse
l’artisanat.
Dès la fin du XIVe siècle, en Italie, les
peintres revendiquent pour le progrès de
leur compétence, caractérisée par le pouvoir
de création, l’audace de l’imagination,
et l’extrême précision du dessin, un statut
social comparable à celui de la poésie.
Le génie Léonard de Vinci va encore plus
loin au XVIe siècle : il ajoute à la peinture
des dimensions qui relèvent du raisonnement
philosophique et de l’exploration de la
nature. L’artiste se met à signer ses œuvres
comme l’écrivain signe ses livres. Mais
c’est seulement au XVIIe siècle que les
beaux-arts deviennent autonomes par rapport
aux arts mécaniques.
« Qui blâme la peinture blâme la nature.
»
— Léonard de Vinci, Carnets
Dans le 3ème cas de figure, l’art perd
toute dimension artisanale.
Le mouvement qui accomplit cette évolution
est l’art contemporain, qui naît après
1945 et rompt fondamentalement avec la tradition
de l’art occidental. En effet, la création
de l’artiste ne repose désormais plus sur
un savoir-faire et une habileté de la main.
Il n’a même plus besoin de « mettre la
main à la pâte », d’intervenir personnellement
dans la production de l’objet d’art, car
la valeur artistique de son « œuvre » réside
dans l’originalité de son concept et son
habileté à le promouvoir. Il n’est plus
artisan, mais théoricien et communiquant.
J’illustrerai les 3 cas de figure avec des
exemples concrets dans les leçons du module.
Comment classifier les différents arts ?
L’ambiguïté de la définition de l’art
entraîne logiquement un problème de nomenclature
: les classifications de l’art varient selon
les époques et les systèmes de pensée.
Je vais d’abord évoquer les classifications
les plus courantes de l’art en général
; puis je vous présenterai les arts dits
« visuels », qui sont les plus essentiels
pour votre culture artistique.
Combien y a-t-il d’arts différents ?
À prendre le mot « art » dans son sens
général, différentes réponses sont possibles.
L’Antiquité grecque comptait 9 « arts
» parce que sa mythologie comptait autant
de muses, les divinités (filles de Zeus)
qui inspirent les artistes. Ces 9 « arts
» sont la poésie épique, l’histoire,
la poésie lyrique, la musique, la tragédie,
l’éloquence, la danse, la comédie, et
l’astronomie. Mais cette classification
n’est plus du tout la nôtre (elle comprend
même des disciplines qui sont pour nous des
sciences, comme l’astronomie ou l’histoire).
Ensuite, au Moyen Âge avait cours la classification,
que j’ai déjà mentionnée, des arts dits
« libéraux » (par opposition aux arts dits
« mécaniques ») : ce sont, pour rappel,
la grammaire, la rhétorique, et la logique
(qui constituent le trivium), et l’arithmétique,
la géométrie, l’astronomie, et la musique
(qui constituent le quadrivium).
En outre, de grands penseurs ont proposé
des classifications intéressantes. Le philosophe
allemand du XVIIIe siècle Kant distinguait
par exemple les arts qui forment des images
(la peinture, la scultpure et l’architecture),
les arts de la parole, et les arts qui stimulent
les sensations (tout particulièrement la
musique). Hegel, un autre philosophe allemand
(qui écrit une génération après Kant),
voit pour sa part 5 arts principaux dont il
estime que le pouvoir d’expression est fonction
de l’abstraction (autrement dit, plus un
art est abstrait, plus il est expressif) : ce
sont l’architecture (le plus concret, donc
le moins expressif), la sculpture, la peinture,
la musique, et la poésie (le plus abstrait,
donc le plus expressif).
Enfin, la classification la plus courante
de nos jours est celle en vertu de laquelle
nous parlons du cinéma comme du « septième
art » :
1. architecture ;
2. sculpture ;
3. peinture et dessin ;
4. musique ;
5. littérature (dont poésie) ;
6. arts de la scène (dont notamment le théâtre
et la danse) ;
7. cinéma.
Et comme je vous l’ai dit, le mot « art
» désigne au sens strict les trois premiers
de cette classification, qu’on appelle également
les arts « visuels ».
Quels sont les arts visuels majeurs ?
Le module de culture artistique de Culture
Express se concentre sur les trois arts majeurs
de la tradition occidentale : la peinture,
la sculpture, et l’architecture.
La peinture consiste à appliquer des couleurs
sur une surface. Les supports privilégiés
par les artistes sont la toile, le papier,
et le bois. La couleur est produite avec divers
types de substances : l’aquarelle, par exemple,
est une peinture à l’eau sur papier ; il
y a également la peinture à l’huile (La
Joconde de Léonard de Vinci en est une) ; les
peintres peuvent encore utiliser de la cire,
de la graisse, ou même des œufs, comme dans
la très ancienne technique de la tempera
(qui existait déjà dans l’Égypte antique).
La sculpture consiste à produire une belle
forme en 3 dimensions. Les deux principales
catégories de sculpture sont le relief, défini
par le fait que la forme repose sur un arrière-plan
(comme avec un clavier d’ordinateur), et
la ronde-bosse, qui peut être observée de
tous les côtés (une statue par exemple).
Les matériaux privilégiés par les artistes
sont la pierre (l’origine étymologique
du mot « sculpture », le latin sculpere,
signifie « tailler la pierre »), le bois,
le métal, ou encore des matières végétales.
Les techniques de création de la forme varient
selon le matériau : le modelage (de la terre,
notamment) est la technique la plus ancienne
; la taille consiste à retrancher un certain
volume d’une matière dure comme la pierre
; l’assemblage consiste, comme son nom l’indique,
à joindre des éléments (comme lorsque l’on
soude des pièces de métal).
L’architecture consiste à construire, à
disposer et à orner les édifices. Étymologiquement,
le terme vient des mots grecs arkhi, « qui
commande », et tekton, « ouvrier » : l’architecture
serait donc l’art de commander aux ouvriers
(et effectivement, en pratique, sur un chantier
moderne, l’architecte leur donne des directives).
Dans le détail, cet art comporte plusieurs
dimensions : l’architecte vise non seulement
à créer un bâtiment qui plaise à l’œil
; mais il doit aussi prévoir la solidité
de l’édifice, l’usage que les hommes
en feront, ou encore son intégration dans
l’environnement. Il a par là, dans l’organisation
de la vie collective, un rôle en vertu duquel
on le compare à une intelligence ordonnatrice
(comme le Grand Architecte de l’Univers
dans la théologie franc-maçonne, ou l’Architecte
dans le film Matrix).
« Ce qui distingue d'emblée le pire architecte
de l'abeille la plus experte, c'est qu'il
a construit la cellule dans sa tête avant
de la construire dans la ruche. »
— Karl Marx, Le Capital
Quels sont les autres arts visuels importants
?
Ont également compté dans l’histoire de
l’art (mais dans une moindre mesure), à
côté de la peinture, de la sculpture et
de l’architecture :
* le dessin, qui consiste à représenter
quelque chose sur une surface au moyen d’un
crayon, d’une plume, d’un pinceau (c’est
souvent une étape préparatoire qui permet
à l’artiste de concrétiser rapidement
son idée et de la présenter au commanditaire)
;
* la gravure, qui consiste à creuser une
matière (comme la pierre, le bois ou un métal)
grâce à divers outils pour créer une représentation
;
* l’orfèvrerie, qui consiste à fabriquer
de beaux objets en métaux précieux (surtout
l’or, qui a donné son nom à l’art, mais
aussi l’argent, par exemple) ;
* la mosaïque (pratiquée dans la Rome antique,
notamment), qui consiste à utiliser des fragments,
appelés « tesselles », de pierre, d'émail,
de verre, ou encore de céramique pour créer
des représentations ;
* l’art du vitrail, qui s’est développé
au Moyen Âge, et qui consiste à assembler
des pièces de verre de couleur pour créer
une représentation (c’est une manière
artistique de laisser passer la lumière dans
un bâtiment).
Quel est le sens de l’art ?
Je vais d’abord évoquer les idées des
grands penseurs de l’Antiquité. Je vous
présenterai ensuite les thèses de référence
sur le sens de l’art. Enfin, je verrai comment
expliquer l’effet de la révolution scientifique
et industrielle sur le sens de l’art.
Comment les penseurs de l’Antiquité voient-ils
l’art ?
Les deux plus grands philosophes de l’Antiquité
grecque, Platon et son disciple Aristote,
ont tous les deux réfléchi au sens de l’art.
La réflexion de Platon est intéressante
à 2 égards :
1. La définition de l'art comme mimêsis
(« imitation » en grec ancien) — Platon
condamne ce que nous appelons les « beaux-arts
» (qui n’existent pas en tant que tels
dans son propos) parce qu’ils ne reproduisent
les choses que dans leur apparence. Par exemple,
une peinture ne rend qu’un seul aspect d’un
lit, contrairement à l’objet matériel,
qui possède l’unité d’une chose (et
ce qui a le plus de valeur, pour Platon, c’est
l’Idée du lit, c’est-à-dire le modèle
intellectuel qui guide l’artisan dans son
travail). Un tableau n’est donc, dans cette
perspective, qu’un simulacre de l’objet
fabriqué par l’homme. Platon met le peintre
au même rang que le poète et le sophiste
: il est un illusionniste.
2. L’essence du Beau — La définition
du Beau de Platon tient en 3 étages : en
premier lieu, une chose est belle en elle-même
lorsqu'elle procure un plaisir sans mélange,
c'est-à-dire un plaisir pur qui ne naît
pas de la cessation d'une peine ; ensuite,
elle est belle si elle est harmonieuse (idée
que j’ai déjà évoquée) ; enfin, elle
est belle si elle conduit le spectateur vers
l’essence suprasensible de la beauté, c’est-à-dire
si elle l’aide à comprendre ce qu’est
fondamentalement la beauté.
La réflexion d’Aristote est elle aussi
intéressante à 2 égards :
1. La dévalorisation des arts « manuels
» — Aristote distingue, d’une part, les
arts mécaniques (dont la peinture, l’architecture,
et la sculpture) qui produisent des objets
; et d’autre part, les arts libéraux (comme
la rhétorique, les mathématiques, et la
musique) qui produisent des objets intellectuels.
Les arts libéraux sont nobles, tandis que
les arts mécaniques, qui mobilisent le corps,
sont serviles. Cette classification des arts
explique l’infériorité sociale de l’artiste.
2. L’imitation de la nature — Aristote
ne dit pas que l’art produit des copies
de la nature, mais qu’il l’imite en tant
que force créatrice : il agence lui aussi
des moyens en vue d’une fin. La nature commet
certes moins d’erreurs que l’art, victime
de la délibération et de la malhabileté
humaines, mais elle est impuissante à créer
certains objets sans la main de l’homme
qui puisse la compléter.
« L’art ou bien exécute ce que la nature
est impuissante à effectuer,
ou bien il l’imite. »
— Aristote, Physique
Quelles sont les thèses de référence sur
le sens de l’art ?
La réflexion philosophique sur le sens de
l’art s’est approfondie depuis Kant.
En voici les thèses les plus pénétrantes
:
* Dans sa Critique de la faculté de juger
(dont la 1ère partie est la « Critique de
la faculté de juger esthétique »), Kant
caractérise la beauté d’une œuvre d’art
par le fait que l’appréciation doit être
partagée par tous. Ainsi, lorsqu’on trouve
une chose belle, on présuppose que cette
beauté est une propriété de la chose qui
doit être reconnue universellement — nous
attribuons aux autres la même satisfaction.
En revanche, lorsqu’on trouve une chose
agréable (le goût du vin, par exemple),
on juge selon son goût personnel, sans présupposer
qu’il en est de même pour autrui.
« Est beau ce qui plaît universellement
sans concept. »
— Kant, Critique de la faculté de juger
* Hegel affirme dans son Esthétique que l'art
est une des voies par lesquelles la conscience
humaine se manifeste. Les étapes de l’histoire
de l’art en apportent la preuve : l’art
symbolique ou oriental manifeste une volonté
d’infini ; l’art classique manifeste un
équilibre parfait entre la forme et le contenu
; et enfin l’art romantique manifeste l’importance
de l’intériorité de l’individu. Hegel
estime que l’art meurt à son époque parce
qu’il n’est plus le meilleur moyen d’exprimer
la conscience humaine.
* Dans Le monde comme volonté et comme représentation,
Schopenhauer définit l’art comme un mode
d’accès à la vérité de l’existence
qui est affranchi de la logique du désir
et du logiciel de l’esprit humain. Cette
conception aura une grande influence sur les
artistes européens à partir de la seconde
moitié du XIXe siècle.
* Dans la théorie marxiste, l’art est un
des moyens par lesquels une classe sociale
exprime la conscience qu’elle a d’elle-même.
Sur le plan des rapports de force entre les
classes sociales, l’art constitue une des
dimensions du phénomène d’hégémonie
culturelle identifié par Antonio Gramsci.
Ainsi, l’art des sociétés bourgeoises
est une des armes idéologiques qui empêchent
la classe des prolétaires de prendre conscience
de ses propres enjeux politiques.
* Nietzsche remet en question le mythe du
génie de l’artiste (notamment dans Humain,
trop humain). Aucune œuvre humaine, quelle
qu’elle soit, n’est le produit d’un
miracle — elle est toujours le fruit d’un
important effort méthodique. Aux yeux de
Nietzsche, les artistes entretiennent l’illusion
afin de se démarquer des artisans, et les
spectateurs y croient pour justifier leur
émotion esthétique.
* Dans La Distinction, Bourdieu réfléchit
au sens de l’art dans le cadre des rapports
de classe. Comme la classe sociale dominante
est celle qui détermine la hiérarchie des
productions culturelles, la culture et le
goût artistiques sont des attributs symboliques
qui marquent l’appartenance à la classe
sociale dominante.
Le progrès technique rend-il l’art inutile
?
On peut comprendre le problème à partir
d’exemples simples : à quoi bon commander
un tableau quand je peux prendre une photo
? À quoi bon passer du temps devant une statue
quand je peux avoir l’image dans mon iPhone
?
La révolution scientifique et industrielle
des sociétés occidentales a bouleversé
le monde de l’art. En effet, le mode de
production artisanal (celui de l’artiste)
disparaît au profit du mode de production
industriel, qui consiste à produire une grande
quantité du même produit en associant les
machines et les travailleurs de la manière
la plus efficiente possible.
L’historien de l’art allemand du XXe siècle
Walter Benjamin affirme dans L’Œuvre d’art
à l’époque de sa reproductibilité technique
que la technique moderne change le statut
de l’œuvre d’art. Certes, les élèves
recopiaient leurs maîtres dans les ateliers
; mais la reproduction de masse par l’imprimerie,
la gravure, la photographie, puis les processus
photomécaniques, chimiques et électriques
— cela change complètement la donne. L’usage
de la sérigraphie (l’imprimerie par pochoirs)
dans le pop art (le mouvement incarné par
Andy Warhol dans les années 1960) est un
exemple emblématique de cette évolution.
Les NFT, les œuvres d’art numériques,
radicalisent la mutation au milieu des années
2010.
Voici précisément comment Walter Benjamin
explique l’effet du progrès technique sur
l’art. Dans les sociétés préindustrielles,
l’œuvre d’art avait une « aura » : puisqu’elle
était unique, la contempler était une expérience
unique, source d’une émotion esthétique
unique, comme l’est la contemplation d’un
beau paysage naturel. Dans les sociétés
industrielles, l’œuvre et l’expérience
de contemplation n’ont plus rien d’unique
; c’est pourquoi l’art a perdu la valeur
d’usage qu’il avait pour l’être humain.
Walter Benjamin n’en conclut cependant pas
que le progrès technique rend l’art inutile
— seulement, il transforme profondément
les conditions de production et de consommation
de l’œuvre d’art.
« À l’époque de la reproductibilité
technique,
ce qui dépérit dans l’œuvre d’art,
c’est son aura. »
— Walter Benjamin, L’Œuvre d’art à
l’époque de sa reproductibilité technique
Je vous expliquerai dans la leçon sur l’art
moderne l’incidence du progrès technique
sur les idées qui animent les artistes, et
sur le monde de l’art en général.
Y a-t-il un progrès en art ?
Mon père est tombé sur ce sujet à son oral
de philo du bac, il y a plus de 40 ans. Mais
la question d’un progrès, c’est-à-dire
d’une transformation graduelle du moins
bien au mieux en matière d’art — cette
question est bien plus ancienne. Pour l’étudier,
je vais vous présenter, dans un ordre d’évidence
décroissante (c’est-à-dire du plus évident
au moins évident) 3 arguments en faveur de
la thèse ; puis 3 arguments qui s’y opposent.
Quels sont les arguments en faveur de cette
thèse ?
En premier lieu, on peut avancer que les produits
sont meilleurs. Autrement dit, les œuvres
s’amélioreraient avec le temps, c’est-à-dire
que l’émotion esthétique qu’elles suscitent
chez le spectateur est plus puissante (intensité
de l’émotion) et plus profonde (complexité
de l’émotion). Les peintures des génies
de la Renaissance italienne paraissent par
exemple plus réussies que celles des meilleurs
peintres du Moyen Âge. Cela peut s’expliquer
par la supériorité de leurs qualités techniques
: le dessin est peut-être plus précis ; les
proportions mieux respectées ; les couleurs
mieux accordées ; etc.
Cependant, cet argument n’est pas valable
pour toutes les époques historiques. L’art
peut même régresser, comme cela fut le cas
après l’apogée de l’Antiquité gréco-romaine.
En deuxième lieu, on peut avancer que les
artistes sont plus compétents. Si les produits
de l’art paraissent plus réussis à une
époque qu’aux précédentes, c’est en
partie parce que les artistes possèdent une
meilleure maîtrise que leurs aînés, ou
bien qu’ils maîtrisent de nouvelles techniques
inconnues de leurs aînés. Par exemple, l’emploi
de la perspective par les peintres italiens
XVe siècle s’est traduit par un progrès
en termes de réalisme : l’image paraît
bien plus fidèle à la réalité. Plus fondamentalement,
le progrès de la compétence des artistes
est rendu possible par leur inscription dans
une tradition. Une génération transmet ses
compétences à la suivante, laquelle s’efforcera,
à son tour, d’élever le niveau d’habileté.
Cet argument est toutefois à relativiser
par le fait qu’un artiste n’est pas forcé
de s’inscrire dans la tradition de ses aînés.
L’art ne progresse pas comme la science.
Enfin, on peut avancer que les médiums sont
plus efficaces. La capacité des supports
des arts visuels à produire l’émotion
esthétique s’améliore avec le temps. Par
exemple, le mur d’une église qui accueille
une fresque est un meilleur médium que le
mur d’une grotte où un homme préhistorique
peint du gibier ; et une toile préparée
pour accueillir la peinture est, à divers
égards, un meilleur médium qu’un mur.
On peut même comparer l’efficacité des
médiums entre différents arts : une vidéo
ne produit-elle pas une émotion esthétique
supérieure à celle produite par une peinture
?
On peut néanmoins objecter à cet argument
que c’est la « technologie » (au sens
large) qui progresse, et non pas l’habileté
à produire de la beauté elle-même.
Quels sont les arguments qui s’opposent
à cette thèse ?
En premier lieu, on peut avancer que l’art
ne s’épanouit pas à toutes les époques.
Ainsi, certaines périodes apparaissent comme
des apogées artistiques, tandis que d’autres
nous laissent peu de chefs-d’œuvre. Par
exemple, la « Haute Renaissance » italienne,
qu’on appelle le Cinquecento — cette période
a accouché de trois des plus grands génies
de l’art occidental, Léonard de Vinci,
Michel-Ange, et Raphaël. Les réussites de
ces artistes étaient si éblouissantes que
la génération suivante en a été désaçonnée
: comment soutenir la comparaison avec de
les chefs-d’œuvre de leurs aînés ?
En deuxième lieu, on peut avancer que les
œuvres d’art ne sont pas comparables (ce
qui rend impossible la conclusion d’un progrès).
En effet, s’il existe bien une tradition
artistique (qui favorise la continuité par
imitation), les générations d’artistes
cherchent également à se différencier les
unes des autres. Le courant des peintres impressionnistes
(XIXe siècle) a par exemple rompu avec la
tradition en renonçant à l’usage académique
de la lumière et en s’écartant des sujets
admis. L’historien de l’art Ernst Gombrich
estime ainsi que l’histoire de l’art est,
sous sa forme la plus simple, l’histoire
de la succession des styles.
« Chaque génération est, dans une certaine
mesure,
en révolte contre les critères de la génération
précédente. »
— Ernst Gombrich, Histoire de l’art
Enfin, on peut avancer que l’état de la
civilisation conditionne le développement
de l’art. Il n’y aurait donc pas de progrès
dans la mesure où, avant d’essayer de se
surpasser les uns les autres, les artistes
travaillent avec les contraintes de leur contexte
socio-économique. La prospérité décuple
les commandes et peut même créer un rapport
de force favorable au créateur (qui pourra
suivre sa propre inspiration plutôt que de
se contenter d’exécuter le projet du commanditaire).
En revanche, une morale sociale austère empêche
les artistes d’exprimer librement leur talent,
et les cantonne aux arts les plus rémunérateurs.
Par exemple, comme le protestantisme est hostile
aux images (dont il craint qu’elles n’éloignent
le fidèle du message originel du christianisme),
son avènement au XVIe siècle a brutalement
réduit l’activité des peintres du nord
de l’Europe (le portrait est le seul genre
qui survit).
Qui sont les artistes ?
Je vais d’abord vous parler de la formation
des artistes. Je vous résumerai ensuite les
caractéristiques essentielles de la condition
de l’artiste. Enfin, j’analyserai cette
condition sous un angle spécifiquement économique
en m’intéressant au « marché de l’art
».
Comment devient-on artiste professionnel ?
L’habileté de l’artiste est le fruit
d’un apprentissage.
Historiquement, la formation des peintres
et des sculpteurs était calquée sur celle
du monde de l’artisanat. Les artistes les
plus réputés dirigent des ateliers, où
les artistes en devenir se forment par la
pratique. Au début, l’apprenti se contente
d’observer ; puis il s’implique de plus
en plus dans les projets ; jusqu’à devenir
lui-même capable de diriger un projet de
A à Z, auquel cas il a le niveau pour créer
son propre atelier. Par exemple, Léonard
de Vinci s’est formé dans l’atelier le
plus important de Florence, celui du très
renommé peintre et sculpteur Andrea del Verrocchio
; puis il a ouvert son propre atelier à 25
ans.
Les choses ont changé au tournant du XIXe
siècle. Les peintres et les sculpteurs sont
désormais formés dans un système dit « académique
», c’est-à-dire inspiré de l’école
où Platon enseignait au début du IVe siècle
avant J.-C. L’enseignement est plus intellectuel
: les élèves étudient les chefs-d’œuvre
anciens pour en assimiler la maîtrise technique.
À ma connaissance, les véritables autodidactes
sont plutôt rares dans l’histoire de l’art
— même s’il y a des exemples étonnants
comme Van Gogh — mais la formation de l’artiste
comporte bien sûr (plus ou moins) une part
d’autodidaxie. Les peintres polymathes de
la Renaissance en sont le meilleur exemple,
qui ont énormément appris en dehors de l’atelier.
Il existe aujourd’hui en France une quarantaine
d’écoles supérieures d’art publiques
(la plus connue étant les Beaux-Arts de Paris).
Et à cela, il faut ajouter les écoles privées.
Plutôt que des peintres ou des sculpteurs,
les établissements forment des graphistes,
des créateurs numériques, des photographes,
des vidéastes, des médiateurs, des animateurs,
etc.
La formation des architectes a connu la même
évolution : le maître d'œuvre (l’ancêtre
de l’architecte) transmettait directement
ses compétences à ses assistants ; puis
sont nées des institutions académiques,
qui délivrent un enseignement théorique
et des diplômes. Dans certains pays comme
la France, l’architecture est une profession
réglementée : le titre d’« architecte
» est conditionné à l’obtention du diplôme
délivré par la vingtaine d'écoles d'architectures,
et contrôlé par l’ordre des architectes.
Quelle est la condition de l’artiste ?
Sa condition est, pendant le plus clair de
l’histoire de l’art, celle de l’artisan.
En voici les 3 caractéristiques principales
:
1. La précarité — Les revenus de la plupart
des artistes professionnels sont faibles et
incertains (puisqu’ils sont des entrepreneurs).
Il n’est pas rare qu’ils doivent accepter
un travail alimentaire pour assurer le vivre
et le couvert. Toutefois, ils se protègent
en s’organisant en corporations (comme les
artisans). En outre, il existe bien une minorité
(plus ou moins large selon les périodes)
d’artistes qui s’enrichissent grâce à
leur talent — c’est un préjugé de croire
qu’un artiste ne peut pas connaître le
succès de son vivant et que ses œuvres ne
seront reconnues à leur vraie valeur qu’après
sa mort (les deux scénarios existent dans
l’histoire de l’art).
2. La servitude créative — L’artiste
travaille le plus souvent à la commande,
c’est-à-dire qu’il met son habileté
au service de la réalisation d’un projet
désiré et imaginé par d’autres. Il existe
certes une marge dans laquelle il peut exprimer
sa créativité, mais elle est souvent mince,
car les clients s’attendent en général
à ce qu’il imite un modèle traditionnel.
3. L’infériorité sociale — L’artiste
étant un artisan, c’est-à-dire un travailleur
manuel, son statut social est inférieur à
celui de l’écrivain. Pendant bien longtemps,
il ne signe pas son travail, et c’est l’œuvre,
elle seule, qui reçoit l’estime publique.
Certains artistes « stars » réussissent
à s’extirper de cette condition difficile
dans les périodes d’épanouissement culturel,
comme le sculpteur Lysippe, le portraitiste
officiel d’Alexandre le Grand — mais c’est
surtout à partir de la Renaissance que la
condition de l’artiste s’améliore. Le
rapport de force économique évolue en sa
faveur, car les élites multiplient les commandes
ambitieuses. Et les grands maîtres donnent
à l’art visuel une dimension intellectuelle
qui rapproche leur statut social de celui
de l’écrivain.
À partir de la Révolution française, le
monde des artistes se divise progressivement,
pour parler très schématiquement, en deux
groupes. D’un côté, les « académiques
» profitent de l’institutionnalisation
de l’art pour s’assurer une situation
confortable ; de l’autre côté, les « marginaux
» rompent avec l’académisme, sacrifient
leur confort quotidien et renoncent à la
reconnaissance immédiate afin d’exprimer
leur créativité (c’est dans ce groupe
que se range la figure de l’artiste maudit
incarnée par Van Gogh).
Qu’en est-il de la condition des métiers
artistiques aujourd’hui en France ?
Les sociologues disent que les métiers auxquels
forment les écoles d’art mènent en général
à des emplois précaires, dépendants, et
éloignés de la vocation initiale (mais après
tout, la désillusion n’est-elle pas un
passage obligé de l’entrée sur le marché
du travail ?). Pour brosser un tableau statistique
grossier, la France compterait à la fin des
années 2010 environ 60 000 artistes professionnels,
et plus de la moitié dépendraient des aides
sociales. Étant donné cette précarité,
les meilleurs débouchés d’une formation
artistique sont bien souvent un poste dans
l’enseignement ou dans l’administration
publique.
Qu’est-ce que le marché de l’art ?
« On peut se foutre de la gueule de l’art,
mais pas de la gueule du marché. »
— Damian Hirst, la star de l’art contemporain
des années 1990
L’emballement financier autour de l’art
contemporain a popularisé l’expression
de « marché de l’art », mais l’art
n’a jamais échappé à la logique économique.
Son prestige tend à nous faire oublier les
considérations matérielles, mais les artistes
ont en réalité, comme les écrivains, l’obsession
de vivre de leur talent.
Voici les acteurs traditionnels du marché
de l’art :
* l’artiste, le producteur qui travaille
seul ou au sein d’une petite entreprise
(l’atelier) ;
* le commanditaire, l’acheteur, qui est
en général une institution (religieuse ou
politique), un membre de l’élite politique
ou économique, ou bien un bourgeois (qui
veut faire faire son portrait, par exemple)
;
* les corporations, ou guildes, dans lesquelles
les artistes s’associent (à l’image des
artisans) pour défendre leurs intérêts
communs (certaines corporations deviennent
puissantes à la Renaissance) ;
* les marchands d’art, apparus à la Renaissance,
qui servent d’intermédiaire entre l’artiste
et l’acheteur (avec le temps, certains marchands
se spécialiseront dans les œuvres nouvelles,
d’autres dans les anciennes, et des multinationales
comme Christie’s et Sotheby’s ont été
créées par des marchands d’art [britanniques,
en l’occurrence]).
Comme je vous l’ai déjà dit, d’ordinaire,
le rapport de force est favorable au commanditaire.
L’artiste a également du mal à se passer
du marchand, qui contrôle l’accès aux
acheteurs. Le commanditaire et le marchand
imposent donc leurs conditions (prix, style,
etc.) aux artistes, même si ceux-ci s’organisent
pour ramener l’équilibre en leur faveur.
La plupart du temps, les commanditaires achètent
les œuvres — je parle surtout des biens
meubles, les peintures et les sculptures — pour
en jouir ; mais le motif de spéculation est
de plus en plus courant à mesure que se développe
le marché de l’art et que se multiplient
par voie de conséquence les opportunités
de faire un profit.
Deux nouveaux acteurs s’imposent à partir
du XIXe siècle :
* l’État, qui intervient (plus ou moins
selon les pays) à la fois en régissant le
goût (par exemple en créant des Académies),
en commandant des œuvres (pour les musées,
notamment), voire en prétendant administrer
le monde de l’art (comme en France) ;
* les critiques, qui guident le public dans
l’appréciation des œuvres (leur fonction
est justifiée par le développement et la
complexification du marché de l’art).
Enfin, l’avènement de l’art contemporain
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale révolutionne
le marché de l’art. Autrefois reniée,
la logique économique devient alors une dimension
essentielle (et assumée) de l’activité
artistique. Je vous expliquerai en détail
cette révolution dans la leçon consacrée
à l’art contemporain.
________________
Alors,
la vidéo vous a plu ?
J’espère que oui.
Je vous rappelle
que c’est un extrait
de ma formation de culture générale
« Culture Express ».
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
cliquez sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
ou bien
sur celui qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
comme d’habitude
n’hésitez pas à m’écrire
dans les commentaires,
et puis SURTOUT
N’OUBLIEZ PAS
que vous n’avez PAS BESOIN
de vous prendre la tête
pour vous cultiver.